hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel where today we are going to play
sifu i am very very excited obviously
i'm playing on ps5 the game comes out in
a couple of days so um i'm playing it
early but this is the full build and
before we jump into it the team at slo
clap actually sent me a creator kit
that i have on the floor here that looks
absolutely beautiful so i thought that i
would just unbox it before we jump into
the gameplay
uh if you just want the gameplay you
just skip ahead this will probably be a
couple of minutes at most otherwise i
will leave a time code as the pinned
comment if you just want to jump
straight to the gameplay but i thought
some people would want to see it i mean
i know they did i posted it on instagram
and so many people like what's in it do
an unboxing so this is me doing that but
if you're here for the gameplay yeah
just jump ahead and we'll have a full
hour of gameplay i just took the little
lock
off of the front of it um so let's open
up the box shall we
okay first up we have
some sort of
pamphlet oh i didn't expect it to do
this it oh how cool
that's gorgeous okay so i guess it opens
from here
how beautiful is that
and yeah these pages kind of
mull over this is going to be some of
our characters i'm guessing
it's gorgeous artwork
i really i don't want to like
mess this up with my
stupid hands um okay so it says
sifu is the story of a young kung fu
student on a path of revenge after his
family's home in martial arts school was
attacked by a mysterious assassination
assassination squad and all the people
he knew were murdered our hero has spent
close to a decade training by himself to
prepare for his day of reckoning the day
has finally come and he is on the hunt
for five murders fajar a street orphan
is that gonna be who these people are
that's that's him he looks cool as hell
dude so it's farja is a street orphan
who is now a botanist for a drug gang
shaun is the heir of a kung fu school
who betrayed his family karaoke is a
japanese artist who became famous after
the day of the massacre
jin fang was the sifu of a kung fu
school before using her influence to
create a vast conglomerate finally yang
who was like a brother to our hero
before turning against him is a powerful
leader working above the city
our hero finally holds revenge within
his reach but for every mistake
time will be the price to pay
that is obviously the big mechanic uh
with sifu is that
as you die
you age and then eventually are
effectively reborn
as a new person and then the back of it
here
also says the entire slo-clap team is
excited to be able to share sifu we hope
you enjoy our game and manage to
overcome your five nemesis
inside the chest you'll find treasures
to bring you good fortune long life and
provide inner peace for the task ahead
good luck on your path don't hesitate to
tag us at seafood game to let us know
how you do um
so this this box again does look
beautiful we have
this gorgeous print
very
nice let me show you the rest of the box
man this is stunning now that it's
actually open
uh
so we have oh this is just gonna be
incense at the top here yeah just some
incense very nice very nice very nice
this is
a wax seal it says
achievement seal
um because there's also wax here so the
state of constant learning the tree
represents the many parts and skills we
learn through experience and practice
there's the tree
on the bottom and
this is gonna be wax yup
to dip the seal in
how cool these are some beads these are
malapeeds the mala is a buddhist rosary
practitioners chant a mantra for each of
the beads there are usually 108 beads on
a mala as this is a very auspicious
number in buddhism according to ancient
teachings there are 108 invisible
threads from each person to the divine
chanting a mantra 108 times awakens see
shreds and aids meditation interesting i
had no idea
very nice
and this
i recognized from the game also sifu on
the back
um but this is kind of like what your
like skill tree looks like in the menu
funnily enough so
that is all
very pretty and i do want to know um
because i imagine this has probably
received some criticism for this
uh all of this is clearly chinese themed
the studio who made sifu are french i
believe they are not a chinese studio
but i know that they did
consult
um with
two chinese partners
i think their
composer
is chinese uh the game is available in
full mandarin a little bit after launch
not immediately on launch
um and then they have a kung fu
consultant who worked on the entire game
as well so it's not like they just did
it without consulting anybody but it is
still worth noting that it isn't from a
chinese studio in the rest of the box i
just lifted this bit up
we have
just looks like
hay really
open it up interesting
this is like a little
mug this is actually feels like very
nice quality it's like textured
mug
i assume this is going to be a tea
thing with another little
little cup
wow oh my there's so much stuff in here
i don't
that's um like a little stand for him
i'm assuming this is tea
maybe not it could be another
contraption of sorts
something breakable i suppose
oh that looks like the top of uh of a
teacup to me uh a teapot rather
it's got the hole in it so i'm guessing
there's a teapot in here
whoa
yeah
it's a whole teapot
i cannot get the front lock of this to
stop swinging
i feel like you just hear it all the
time
there you go
how beautiful
gorgeous stuff though wow
put that on there
and then
sit this
on here
[Music]
oh it's gorgeous i don't have anything
like this it's so like such a nice
way to um
give people green tea is probably what
i'll do with it i don't think there's
any tea in here it is absolutely
beautiful i will keep all of that i'll
try out the wax seal i've never tried
one before it's really neat um time to
play the game let's do it all right
let's jump in
i'm excited to see how the story starts
because i had not seen that obviously
if i came over a tiny bit
that should work
um and hopefully this is in sync i just
upgraded my hardware
um
seems like it should be
that
looks right to me
yes yes
all right
let's do it
i can feel the rain
the jewel sense kicked in i love that so
much
hope it never gets old
okay
this looks pretty
i feel like it's probably not a game
that incentivizes exploring very much
it's probably pretty
pretty straight through oh you want me
to punch the door
oh my hello
oh
i will take a whole game of that it's so
satisfying what's going on my gosh who
are you uh
who's fast who wants to go first
i did not expect him to sound like that
okay
god that's so good
oh you broke my um my posture huh
i didn't know they could do that
stick yeah
[Laughter]
hell yeah let's go
[Music]
oh my god
it's so fun
[Music]
yes good can i keep this i would like to
continue amazing
i didn't expect that i thought you said
they'd put up a fight
i'm barely breaking a sweat
um
hello sweep the place
nobody leaves
sure
his stick is way cooler than mine
um
the voice acting is a little bit off for
me for some reason
oh yeah just casually breaking just
breaking chairs as you walk through them
that's a strong stance you have sir
that these are like
if you can break that
that plastic and steel chair by walking
through it you would kill this man he is
ded dead
wow
okay
it's really pretty the environments are
beautiful
looks like there probably aren't any
collectibles or anything though maybe
later in the game
but so far
not
dual sensors doing the rain thing again
it's the best i love it
who the hell is that hello friends
i can throw this at you
i'm not sure
i'm really sorry that i just glossed you
that brutally my friend
woof
how can i go up these stairs
hey party people
you should never have come back
nice to see you
it's been a while
oh what is this
don't mind if i do
oh i still have the gloss
[Music]
god i love that
that's so sick
ah that was an accident a thing that
could make this a little bit tough um is
the npcs don't
like wait turns to attack you like they
do in a lot of other games
and i feel like you could potentially
have somebody try to attack you
um that you just may not see
if the camera goes goes close up
unclear though um
not going up there
oh yeah it's a broken stair
all right let's keep moving
another friend
um
i like your emo haircut dude you listen
to my chemical romance much
how do you feel about gerard way
would you like to chat about him
sometime
not that i can talk
about the emo fringe since i was like
12.
stop
that was cool very dramatic
yang of course
you've gotten slow
sifu so did these people murder my
family
they did right that was a massacre you
know why i'm here don't you
just step aside
oh i'm here to get something not fight
him
you were a mistake
hmm
uh i should never have taught you
now you know too much
by returning here tonight my first boss
fight i think a second chance
let's get spicy
all right i'm ready this time i will do
what i must
you saying you're gonna kill me sir
all right
let's see what you got
damn i'm missing that first hit every
time i'm just not diving that parry
right he's a little bit different uh in
terms of timing oh what happened
um to
all the other enemies we fought which is
cool so he should be you know
oh he's kicking my butt he's kicking my
butt not having it
not today
sir let me get that stamina back
he's got so much more than me and he's
so old
maybe it won't be a problem
i'm unsure if i'm supposed to
carry every hit or just the first one
and then hold block i think maybe i'm
supposed to parry everyone individually
and i haven't been doing that yeah i am
okay good to know good to know
it's definitely a little bit harder to
time but it helps yeah official okay
that makes sense
um there we go eye strike boom
get wrecked old man
i'm sure that's not it seems too easy
that makes sense
nothing like just two dudes hanging out
in the rain laying some hands on each
other
as you do when i look into your eyes
i see nothing but a frightened angry
child
hush
oh he really got me on that one
damn
oh
we did like a cool recovery thing
damn he's so fast
he's nimble elderly these days
that i'm so bad at dodging that one
attack whatever it is
oh it's because he lunges into it i
think
so i'm miss timing it
oh or it's because it's low and i'm not
blocking um
low maybe
and i got it there
i do look like i'm a lot bigger than him
yeah i need to do better job at
countering though
just like making sure you actually hit
the counter when you see red
oh you done did him right with the
knuckle
i just kill him
did i just murder the old man
no it's definitely fun
there's some things that i for sure need
to learn
[Music]
but so i should five minutes in or
whatever
show yourself
oh
um oh uh i'm gonna go go
is this the bad guy
oh they totally could be
i'm not sure
or am i joining them
what
excuse me
oh my god
i didn't expect that
father
oh damn wow that's an interesting start
well kowloon knights i think is the
chinese company they worked with
wow what an opening damn
oh
so he's the one the one with the hair
[Music]
[Music]
i guess the
thing here is its suggestion is her
training is
[Music]
all about uh
oh no way it is them oh there you go
lion holotech lion hoe attacks a high
low attack
what is it hold l1 and then down
how am i supposed to know if they're
higher
you punk
oh okay i see yeah you kind of have to
you have to you literally do it's not
tap
l1 for those it is literally hold and
then you kind of pivot backwards
[Music]
what
keep feeling my um
charger thing move
um
[Music]
oh that's cool
[Music]
that's dope as hell i want whatever
those are
damn
yeah i imagine when we actually do these
boss fights they're probably just gonna
get hotter and hotter
which is always a fun time
[Music]
the ceo
oh cool
good to know
i'm gonna do a lot of sweeps i reckon
that's awesome okay
[Music]
so then how did i not die
how did he not kill me
that's him
[Music]
[Music]
yeah trained a whole life for this huh
wow he really
got an advantage on me there
very cool intro sequence
very cool oh that was awesome that's so
hype let's go
okay i remember this from the uh
let me just start the mission
what do we have right now information
about anybody
sean i met him several times when i was
a kid our fathers knew each other as
kung fu monsters i can't believe you
took part in their debts
she's involved in an event called the
burning taking place in the club i need
to get that early when it's not too
crowded classic the club
an infamous nightclub in the city the
owner is a good friend of sean's i
remember his father complaining about
the guy's attendance at school it
appears clientele are much better so
that's i think where that um the preview
was where i uploaded games away from
that
welcome to your sanctuary a refuge for
the terminally ill grants them access to
a range of traditional healing methods
to try and alleviate their pain but it's
gained a strange reputation over the
years thanks to its so-called medical
miracles interesting i wonder how that's
gonna
tie in
oh so i will have to get some items
that's for sure like i'm gonna have to
get keys and [ __ ]
trained and raised by my father and sifu
we were close he taught me a lot over
the years ah yang
damn that is like a
picture of your dad he disappeared with
his wife and daughter when i was still a
child he came back years later and
murdered my father in cold blood
he now lives above the city and runs a
traditional healing center but he
doesn't appear to be in touch with the
world
so that's his sealant healing center i
suppose it's interesting okay
alongside my father jing fang was highly
renowned and respected amongst the
city's kung fu monsters she was always
the first to defend the underprivileged
and helpless and always held a strong
sense of justice i don't know why she
turned against them but she will pay for
that now she has become the head of a
vast and extremely powerful corporation
she's still helping those in need albeit
with greater means but her sudden
increase in wealth is very suspicious
the highest building in the city located
in a recently constructed district
jinfang has an office on the top floor
of the building oh that should be cool
looking forward to seeing the different
environments
karaoke's past is hard to navigate all i
know is she is japanese and rumors tie
her to the underworld world
something must have happened to force
her into exile here in china she now
runs an art museum she works there day
and night on her most ambitious
exhibition to date
the museum is brand new high-class
building financed privately
and released
after a game over or give up you can
start you can choose the level you want
to start from among the ones you have
unlocked you'll start the level at the
youngest age you were when you reached
it skills and upgrades unlocked during
previous runs will be lost but all items
in intel under detective board as well
as permanently unlock skills we retain
that make sense
some attacks can be punished by
performing the right defense deflect or
avoid deflect the attack will be parried
leaving an opponent open to a counter
attack or throw avoid time slows down
for the duration of the attack any hit
on an enemy during this window will stun
them interesting
stunt opponents cannot defend themselves
leading them open to attacks or throws
several stuns in a row can lead to a
day's state where opponents cannot
defend themselves for several seconds
okay
god break attack deal a massive amount
of structure damage
you should always try to avoid them they
are indicated by an enemy's glowing
limbs
throws cannot be blocked or defected you
can only avoid them they are indicated
by glowing limbs and a red circle okay
you gain xp by defeating enemies xp
allows you to buy skills for your
current run once a skill has been bought
you can consolidate it to be unlocked
across all your runs that's probably
something i'm going to want to figure
out and focus on
after each death the pendant increases
its death counter then when rising you
age the number of years
the same number of years
right yeah as the is increase the
pennant gradually loses its power and
the coins eventually break once there
are no more coins remaining you can't
rise again and your next death leads to
a game over
this all seems pretty complicated but it
i imagine we'll we'll
flow pretty well once we're actually
into it um structure represent your
ability to defend yourself and fight
structure is impacted each time you're
hit
that's like your stamina
if you take too many hits structure will
eventually break leaving you open to
attacks for a short time deflecting
slash powering attacks prevent you from
having a structure broken
avoiding attacks regenerates a small
amount of structure
you can break an enemy structure by
attacking or deflecting such pairing
their attacks once the structure's
broken take them down
cool
oh this is that first room
no way
wow it really is i remember seeing the
bonsai
oh cool
surely they know i'm still here but
maybe they don't
didn't didn't assume anything of me
skill tree
i currently cannot unlock anything
because i have not done anything
all right
let's
head out
machete mustache who
he's he's the one who cut my throat that
night that is what happened my god he's
the first on my list he works for a gang
as a botanist and never leaves that
warehouse
okay how do we how do we go
let's do it
here
the squats huh
[Music]
cool map i think that might be the map
that's very neat
i'm excited let's do it
i missed the rain
okay
they've blocked the entrance to the
warehouse
need to find another way inside
that's dramatic
somebody seen me
no
okay
guessing the glowy gate is it let's go
get lost
nothing here nothing here for you punk
i warned you [ __ ]
absolutely slapped mate you just got
slapped about boss man
hang on i'm going to sweep you what's
that
and then and then
yeah
get out of here get out of my face
so i'm thinking that yeah there is
there's not going to be any stuff to
collect
um so exploring is probably not
necessarily environments so just here to
look nice
which i
i'm cool with
except that i will pick up this weapon
i really do want to explore though
clearly don't i'm doing it [ __ ] you do
it in here pal
so spicy
came to the wrong place did i
oh i love the way they do the camera
junkies
i don't think they'll be a problem
eating crap out of them anyway i guess
man you could like feel the heat like
this place looks
[Music]
hot it's just out here i think
[Music]
what does this say
skull letter investigate
locked until we [ __ ] say so i found
this note stuck on a door blocking my
way into the warehouse
if i can get it open it's really useful
shortcut uh i'll be a
turn around situation i can't get out
there now so i guess i do have to go
upstairs huh
there's nothing through here
that'll be a real metroidvania i'm
guessing
[Music]
sorry about your face
the weapons make you
so much stronger
it's awesome
hey you
i like the way she's holding it too like
that backward stance is really cool
i can make it
just need to run at it oh okay
also i like her voice um
voice acting a little bit better than uh
than the dude i think
oh i didn't think he was going to do
that
she has the weapon
you cute though
all the knees
the knees nope
did you just pick up another one he did
my bottle now thanks for letting me know
it's there
gonna beat the crap out of you now let's
sleep that's fine
purple mist
the drug produced here it appeared a few
years after the death of my father and
its use has increased dramatically
throughout the city interesting
i'm into the world building too liking
it
what's up with your bathroom anything
cool going on in here
sort of like a doll i guess
is that telling me something was there
more bottles
i'm all right with my one but thank you
for letting me slide over that table
open up oh my hello my friends yes check
this [ __ ] clown out hush
help you with something
yes
get out of my way
oh
the war
the whole way
it's like the film
let's see
it's definitely made my timing a little
bit different than perspective shift
what's the name of that movie is owlboy
thinking the right thing
my posture hey
oh i would have thought i did okay good
to know
i pity you
okay
it's fair
i can unlock stuff now
um
for staff weapons a wide attack powerful
strike to the enemy's knee knocking back
for a while no
snap kick
spin hook kicker can't believe you would
have a high kick oh multiple enemies i
can't afford it damn i would have gone
with that one
face smash focus cost two bars
weapon catch let's do that that sounds
super helpful
let's do it
and let's get up
yep
21 i'm basically ancient want some more
[ __ ]
[ __ ] she's armed he says about the thing
that i just picked up from their floor
get absolutely wrecked mate i'm not
having it i'm not having it
oh he tried to do the the glowy one on
me
that's the first time i'd seen one of
those where you gotta dodge backwards or
whatever
maybe i should swap it out just because
this will break
yeah that
cool
the music's awesome
damn i'm like so into this
atmospherically
this place is too exploring here huh
dawg wants to wrap this up
hey
hey
[Music]
that down
i actually don't know how to throw yet
sure i'll figure it out
anything else to pick up
anything
i would like to always have weapon
this the broom would be cool
i can yeah let's go
that's where it came from
hello anybody need any sweeping
i'm glad you're wearing a mask thank you
i knocked his mask off
that's what you get
damn nice kitchen
that's a lot of space
you know expensive this would be in la
um
okay i would like to throw
um
throw weapon is r1
yeah good sorry about that love
you were just mine in your business
maybe i'm the bad guy
some scaffolding one of the biggest
industries in the world
scaffolding guys we got
i can
damn you
oh that was a good hit oh oh he done me
good there okay
i can't afford anything
i don't know how long the level is so i
don't know how worried i should be about
aging
[Music]
oh i thought you were down
i did the thing
it's interesting because it's like
the further i go i feel like oh you did
it um i feel like the more nervous i'm
gonna get
in terms of um stole his
you can't have game over
obviously
oh no
i didn't think that would happen
oh
dude he's doing a real good one on
drop your me
i do not want to drop my weapon
i would like to do anything but that
oh i missed time to sweep this time the
sweep there's gonna be a little tiny cut
there um my elgato froze i'm having like
this weird issue with one in my usb
ports and i didn't realize
um so you lost i don't know the end of
this fight sorry about that oh is that
red bull
nice gives you wings
the warehouse
i'm getting closer that's the warehouse
okay
this music's so cool
what the hell
oh what's this
uh
interesting
wait these are different
pick one reward but max age to unlock
means i have to be one of these ages to
get this or
which of these would i want health
gained on takedowns that seems like what
i would want right
and we can open this country right now
um
i can't afford some stuff
okay what was the thing that i really
liked the look of it was this right
yeah let's do that one
yep
still look through everything else the
weapon catch i have not used yet
double palm focus yeah i don't want to
do the stuff that costs two bars but it
probably it could end up being worth it
i guess like a lot of this game is kind
of trying
gonna be trial and error
um figuring out which of the things that
you like and that keep you alive the
longest probably
flowing claw
fast and a basic striker leaves your
back facing the enemy
that's interesting
crooked foot
yeah i probably should look at throws
duck strike their handed
invert throw
i want that
[Music]
i see the permanent unlock so we'll save
those for now is the thing
as i play through it i will i will not
be doing my
permanent ones
um okay also yeah i did uh
i did get another age up uh
that's not the way forward
very nice
good day friends
the sweep is so good
nice another jump here
i can make it okay
if you say so my friend
ah what y'all doing
nothing i guess
dominoes nope
all right let's do it sorry about your
face
did i just land in cash shame i'll have
to throw you back through
oh
hell yeah
okay i'm a bit scared of you if i'm
being honest
oh
oh no uh
okay avoid throws hold and
oh [ __ ]
i did i didn't do it right that was my
bad
i'm scared i'm real scared of you
i was hoping i could pick something up i
cannot okay
damn it it's like i'm not tapping it
right [ __ ] i i mean i probably deserve
that i probably deserve that
i just panicked
fine
28 that's my age you've got
determination not trying to be my age in
real life
damn it man
i'm so scared of him because i don't
know what he's gonna do
okay okay we're all right we're all
right we're all right
i really just panicked
so it's like you have to hold l1
oh that that's it's i it's it's a good
system it's just
a little difficult to remember but i'm
sure i'll get it
it's like the hitting the left thumb
stick it becomes the parry
um rather than holding out one drug
money dirty money no doubt blood money
too nice it sounds like a wrap
are we getting through it am i getting
through it
i really do want to fill these all up
cool yeah
she's got some floating money a little
floating money back there
that's chill am i moving this stuff
around yeah money
physics let's just take all this and and
be off with it
the botanist can i don't know continuous
botany what do i care
hello oh oh what the [ __ ]
oh
i did not mean to do that
okay
i might have missed some things up there
oh hey bud
glad to see you washing hands though
good hygiene appreciate good hygiene
damn i'm like super upset i accidentally
fell maybe maybe it wouldn't be a thing
ladies
no
come on speed ladies up
i don't want to be late for the club
i plan to win fake tonight you hate to
be late for the club
who in the [ __ ] are you
it's a valid question man
anybody got any items in here
i'd love to see it
i feel like i heard somebody pick
something up but i could be wrong oh he
did damn
i missed it
oh they had my back
so i was that's that's an interesting
thing worth noting is i was holding
parry but because i was facing away from
him it didn't work
all right
oh god
30. so your damages go up as you age
that's super neat
just gonna bounce just a little bit just
gonna run away a bit got some
stamina back like oh that was cool
damn
damn
i don't even really know what i did
wrong man
okay
um i will note my thumb is having a bit
of trouble with this game
but i'll take a look at the uh
accessibility options
for anyone who doesn't know
a lot of the reason that i got so
involved in accessibility is that uh i
have tendonitis in my wrists
which means that any rapid movement i
get real soul
which is obviously
very bad for
uh any game where you have to tap
buttons a lot which naturally i do have
to do
um this game is certainly contributing
to that
maybe you won't be able to play it for
long periods of time
let's get the better of you
just want to pick up the bat there we go
[Music]
let's see
i'm not sure yeah what that means yet
i don't know what to make of like
him blowing or what i'm supposed to do
about it you know
damn man
the glowy guys kicked my butt
well i would ask you the same question
because i really don't know why you
won't die on a mechanical level oh i
look different
faster i've noticed it how cool
um
yeah because it wasn't in the tutorial
what the glowing means i don't think in
any case mess that up real bad
um i wonder if there's anything to pick
up around here
i will take it oh a couple of things huh
club flyer
the burning 10 pm the club that's why i
hope to face sean i overheard one of the
thugs talking about betting on something
going down there tonight so that is the
thing that i did in the preview build
god this music's so cool
hey somebody with like a modern
laptop i'm trying to figure out like
what era this is set in what time period
what is that noise
just a fan
i don't figure out where it's coming
from
keep on moving did i get some blue in my
head
i think i did
girl you fine
okay
i'm just going to take this one because
in theory is new up
all right
it's probably one open
someone here must have the keys the keys
you all got keys in here oh no these
guys look scary
give me back my back
damn it no leave me alone leave me alone
oh my god
ah you hate to see it okay what else can
i get here
oh yeah i don't even have a focus attack
so let's do that i guess
just to have one
it's happening fast man
it's really like real life
oh i so i did have that i just wasn't
using it
oh i thought i dodged it no stop let me
learn
oh
it's very stressful
okay we got the keys moving through the
air house will be a lot easier with the
keys
i am going to take a look at
remapping options
um
well
it's heavy maybe maybe i can't it's so
my the problem that i have is um
it's tapping square that is difficult if
i could put it on
[Music]
like an r1
okay i can
give that a try it'll make my life a lot
easier
am i missing them no maybe you can't
oh no they're just here okay so
so we can i feel like i'm actually not
going to i will when i continue to play
the game
i'm not going to do that right now
because i feel like that's probably not
what people are going to want to see but
i will need to and it's good good for
people to see the accessibility options
that um
yeah for anyone like me who has trouble
with
any particular setup i can't do a lot of
tapping with my right thumb
these will be um that we can shift them
out but i can
i can deal with it for the next hour or
so you know
uh
maximum structure
structure regain increased structure
gain unsuccessful avoid i'm not doing a
lot of avoiding if i'm being perfectly
honest
so then we're gonna have to do this one
that's what i can afford
okay
keep moving
that hallway sequence was so cool
started this game is very neat
mmm that purple
i'm sorry you were just doing your job
probably
i apologize
you i don't feel like maybe deserve that
honestly it amazes me
i'm quite sure about the kung fu madam
yes
yeah everybody seems chill enough
not on my watch
oh i don't know what it means
i really need to figure it out no get up
you guys are just fighting a 47 year old
out here and you feel fine with that
just gonna back up a little bit
sweet
i really thought i dodged that one i
would have parried that right really
thought i would have
um
we've already got that
i haven't even done that it hasn't
worked um
and stuff weapons
on a push to enemy
give it a shot
yeah
let's try it
really you want some more
i don't
thank you very much
oh it's like you can hear the like bone
crunching noises
keep missing those sweeps
how'd he do that
i don't know what it means
ah damn
i feel like it's getting hotter
and that that's probably because i'm
getting less health right
over time
damn it would you just die
i prefer not to oh i'm so old oh so
frail
you wouldn't beat up your nan
i can and i will
so [ __ ] cool i'm like getting super
stressed though as i'm aging for sure
okay purple flower
the flower used to create the purple
mist
i think there's anything else in here
it doesn't look like it but i will take
a look up here anyway
yet
okay
let's roll
awesome nobody gets through oh
i get real scared of the big guys
dissecting me
i don't think so
okay
it's pretty sick
[Music]
is he getting up okay that was actually
fine and quite cool
the sweep is good i just keep uh
accidentally doing it too far away
when you when you light it up it works
out okay
nothing
all right
just trying to say hi to jafar
not a big deal i'm just gonna hang out
say hi ask him if he would like to die
for
literally cutting my throat when i was a
child
okay
let's do that one
cool
i wonder if there's anything you can do
to age down probably not right
really is hurting my wrist though i'm
like need to put ice on this
okay
keycard a pass key for a room at the
sanctuary
wait isn't the sanctuary over here
i'm not gonna use that for ages two more
things
oh we creeping up on him
we getting close
oh damn it
i should have gone through the door
that's my bad
okay guns
this is
what
what
the botanist is magic
all right
oh that was good
and broke it
he's cool
oh gonna need to dodge that okay i
strike let's go
no damn it
okay i think we'll be fine to get
through this though
um anything i can really use right now
yeah sure why not
oh getting so old
but so strong
what's
oh i didn't even see you
you saw the [ __ ]
i need to back up
not leave me alone just give me give me
some give me some stamina back please
leave me alone
didn't work he did not leave me alone
mode two is it all right
what oh
oh my it's got real anime what the hell
that's cool
okay
what the heck
who said you could do that oh you put
the knife back
just like the old days
[Music]
he's real fast
oh that was cool
hey i was walking
i guess you can't really block a knife
damn man i feel like i'm gonna die oh
i'm so scared
okay
how old are we now
i feel like you're back your back's not
cut out for this
stop it
oh
[Music]
[Music]
damn
oh
i'm so scared
yeah i feel like i'm like
nice just barely even touching him
[Music]
do the eye strike
i should have dodged that
[Music]
my hands are so sweaty
jesus
oh my god
i have spent eight long years preparing
them
that was cool he was very cool it's
super interesting that the further that
you get in the game because you know
you're getting closer and closer to
failing the
mission the more stress you get
that is a
very
interesting thing to like reckon with
mentally
um oh this is we're back home
i guess we did it
damn
yeah i got so stressed towards the end
we did miss stuff damn it damn it damn
it damn it we missed
two things that that door in that
elevator i swear to god
so i guess that's probably the average
length of a mission seems like i should
maybe leave it about there
um
the game's very cool i definitely feel
like i have more learning to do and i
like barely looked at uh
this i mean i was doing that sweep and
the palm strike pretty often
i wasn't great at doing my post parry
stuff
directional throw post parry around a
stunned enemy i wasn't doing that at all
so we should do more of that
while running on a pushed enemy light
attacks push kick around house kick
definitely worth
was before last time that's the one i
bought looking into that and also
looking at um
yeah what skills to actually lean into
it's in a
interesting amount of experimentation i
think and like thinking about which ones
you want to
like in my head it could be worth just
grinding so like doing things for a long
amount of time just to get the the lots
of xp um for the permanent unlock
and like letting yourself die in a
mission just so that you know that
you've gone through and done that
um and you've unlocked some of them for
further playthroughs probably i can
permit and unlock that
replay that for me
i don't really want that one though
when pushed regain your balance
it's not that good to me that i didn't
use that one
i would do permanent unlock
it would be probably that
yeah i'll have to i'll have to think
about it it's super cool um i definitely
need to remap
uh buttons so that i can play probably
i'll probably do it to a shoulder button
um of course happy to show everybody
else some of those accessibility options
there but love the music
very into the tone i don't want to stop
playing like this is this is rad very
cool game um i suspect just based on how
long that took that it's not going to be
very long like probably under 10 hours
which i'm not super surprised by i guess
we'll have to wait and see
um but yeah i'm i am very into it let me
know if you guys have any questions or
you want to see any more of it
it's a good time it's a good time um
yeah thank you so much to slow clap for
sending over
the box and the game of course uh
they're both awesome
and i will see you guys next time bye